[Music]
we have to embrace the inconsistency of
our own minds not as a bug but as a
feature that we are in essence brought
here by the forces of selection we are
the products of systems of selective
pressures and what they seem to do is to
create the ability to learn many many
different programs and often
contradictory programs within the same
mind the question is why have we put
such an extraordinary emphasis on
intellectual consistency so that we are
constantly alerted to the hypocrisy of
others but we are seemingly blind to it
in ourselves our mind is constructed
with an architecture that allows us to
run various sandbox where we can
experiment with the ideas of others
without actually becoming the other can
we run another mind in emulation perhaps
not as well as its original owner but
can we run that mind well enough to
understand it to empathize with it and
to argue and spar with it to achieve
some kind of better outcome where we are
actually able to turn foes into dancing
partners as we come to show that we've
actually understood perspectives
different from our own the biggest
objection to this way of thinking is is
that it's somehow a kind of a cheat that
hypocrisy is being summoned by another
name but I think this is actually
incorrect I think that we have these
sand boxes for example so that we can
fight more effectively a foe that we
feel we must defeat so for example
recently I talked about the importance
of being able to run a jihadi sandbox in
our minds if we want to understand the
forces that are behind Islamic terror
and its effect on what I think are
relatively fragile Western sensibilities
about life and death and so if we if we
choose not to empathize with the other
to say that so much is beyond the pale
we are probably not going to be
very effective and understanding that
the other does not see itself as evil
it does not see itself as an enemy that
must be fought I don't necessarily need
to agree with it but to demonstrate that
I can't even run the program simply for
the purpose of social signaling see the
height of folly how do we hope to become
effective if we can't guess what the
other will do next there are limits to
this we have to have a certain kind of
consistency of mind but the idea that
you can't be capable of running a
die-hard rationalist materials atheist
program as well as a program that says
perhaps I will open myself to
transcendental states and if I need to
enter per morph eyes those as coming
from a deity perhaps the idea is that
that architecture is not what a Richard
Dawkins would suggest as a kind of mind
virus but in fact it's a facility that
we choose to deny ourselves in our peril
what if we're trapped on a local maximum
of fitness and in fact we need to get to
higher ground but the idea is that the
traversal of the so called adaptive
Valley where we have to make things much
much worse before they get much better
what if the idea is that cannot
generally be attempted rationally that
we need a modicum of faith a belief that
we cannot reference to any sort of
informations that we could end up
trapped on local Maxima forever but I
think it's really important to consider
that some people may be able to traverse
the adaptive Ally without belief in a
deity some may need a temporary belief
in the deity so I may be able to
reference some sort of a transcendental
state and steal ourselves in order to
make the journey but however it's
accomplished there are times when it
would appear that all hope is lost and
that if we are not to end our days stuck
on these local maximum whatever we have
achieved that we have to fundamentally
experiment with ways of thinking if only
temporarily to get us to higher ground
[Music]